you know been talking about the brain
as if it's something separate
from the human that carries it a little
bit
like whenever you talk about the brain
it's easy to forget that that's like
that's us um like how much do you
how much is the whole thing like
predetermined
like how much is it already encoded in
there
and
the actions the decisions
the judgments this you mean like who you
are
who you are oh yeah yeah okay great
question right so there used to be a big
debate about nature versus nurture and
we now know that it's
always both you can't even separate them
because
you come to the table with a certain
amount of nature for example your whole
genome
and so on the experiences you have in
the womb like whether your mother is
smoking or drinking
things like that whether she's stressed
so on those all influence
how you're gonna pop out of the womb
from there
everything is an interaction between all
of your experiences
and the and the nature what i mean is
i think of it like a space time cone
where you have
you drop in the world depending on the
experience that you have you might go
off in this direction or that direction
in that direction
because there's interaction all the way
your experiences determine
what happens with the expression of your
genes so some genes get repressed
some get expressed and so on and you
actually become a different person based
on your experiences
there's a whole field called epigenomics
which is or epi
epigenetics i should say which is about
the epigenome
and that is the you know sort of the
layer that sits on top of the dna and
causes the genes to express differently
that is directly related to the
experiences that you have so if
you know just as an example they take
rat pups and you know one group is sort
of placed away from their parents and
the other group is
groomed and licked and taken good care
of that changes their gene expression
for the rest of their life they go off
in different directions in this
in the space time cone um so
yeah this is this is of course why it
matters that we
take care of children and pour money
into things like education and good
child care and so on
for children broadly um because these
formative years matter
so much so is there a free will
this is this is a great process for the
for the absurd high-level philosophical
questions no no these are my favorite
kind of questions
here's the thing here's the thing we
don't know if you ask most
neuroscientists they'll say
that we can't really think of how you
would get free will in there because as
far as we can tell it's a machine it's a
very complicated machine enormously
sophisticated 86 billion neurons about
the same number of glial cells
each of these things is as complicated
as the city of san francisco each neuron
in your head has the entire human genome
in it it's expressing
millions of gene products these are
incredibly complicated biochemical
cascades each one is connected to 10 000
of its neighbors which means you have
you know
like half a quadrillion connections in
the brain so it's it's incredibly
complicated
but it is fundamentally appears to just
be a machine
and therefore if there's nothing in it
that's not being driven by
something else then it seems it's hard
to
understand where free will would come
from so that's the camp that
pretty much all of us fall into but i
will say our science is still quite
young
and you know i'm a fan of the history of
science and what
the thing that always strikes me is
interesting is when you look back at any
moment in science
everybody believes something is true and
they just they simply didn't know about
you know what einstein revealed or
whatever and so
who knows and they all feel like that
we've at any moment in
history they all feel like we've
conversed to the final answer exactly
exactly like all the pieces of the
puzzle are there
and i think that's a funny illusion
that's worth getting rid of
and and in fact this is what drives good
sciences recognizing that we don't have
most of the puzzle pieces
so as far as the free will question goes
i don't know
at the moment it seems wow it would be
really impossible to figure out how
something else could fit in there but
you know 100 years from now
our textbooks might be very different
than they are now i mean
could i ask you to speculate where do
you think free will
could be squeezed into there like what's
that even
um is it is it possible that our brain
just creates kinds of
illusions that are useful for us or like
what
where where could it possibly be
squeezed in well
let me let me give a speculation and
answer to your very nice
question but but you know don't and the
listeners podcast don't quote me on this
yeah exactly i'm not saying this is what
i believe to be true but let me just
give an example i give this at
the end of my book incognito so the
whole book of incognito is about you
know all the what's happening in the
brain and essentially i'm saying look
here's all the
reasons to think that free will probably
does not exist but at the very end i say
look imagine that you are
um you know imagine that you're a
kalahari bushman
and you find a radio in the sand and
you've never seen anything like this
and you you look at this radio and and
you realize that when you turn this knob
you hear voices coming from their voice
is coming from it
so being a you know a radio materialist
you
try to figure out like how does this
thing operate so you take off the back
cover
and you realize there's all these wires
and when you take out some wires
the voices get garbled or stop or
whatever and so what you end up
developing is a whole theory about
how this connections pattern of wires
gives rise to voices
but it would never strike you that in
distant cities there's a radio tower and
there's invisible stuff beaming
and that's actually the origin of the
voices and this is just necessary for it
yeah so i mentioned this just
as a speculation saying look how would
we know what we know about the brain for
absolutely certain is that if when you
damage pieces and parts of it
things get jumbled up but how would you
know if there's something else going on
that we can't see like electromagnetic
radiation
that is what's actually generating this
yeah
you paint a beautiful example of uh
of how totally because we don't know
most of how our universe works how
totally off-base we might be with our
science yeah
until i mean we i mean um yeah i mean
that's
inspiring that's beautiful it's kind of
terrifying
it's humbling it's all all of the above
and the important and the important part
just to recognize is that of course
we're in the position of having
massive unknowns and you know
we have of course the known unknowns and
that's all the things we're pursuing in
our labs and trying to figure out that
but there's this whole space of
unknown unknowns things we haven't even
realized we haven't asked yet
you